vamos a hacer algunos problemas que
tratan de ecuaciones y desigualdades
entonces empecemos con este problema 2
de aquí dice que debemos definir las
variables y traducirlas en las
siguientes traducir las siguientes
expresiones a desigualdades perdón
entonces parte a una autobús tiene
capacidad para 65 pasajeros o menos así
que en la parte a sea x la capacidad ok
o el número la capacidad digamos del
autobús ok vamos a llamarlo xy están
diciendo que en el autobús caben 65
personas o menos así que x tiene que ser
menor o igual x tiene que ser menor o
igual que 65 y ponemos ese igual allí o
ese menor o igual porque puede ser
incluso 65 verdad nos dice claramente
que son 65 o menos así que también puede
ser 65 vámonos salve la suma de dos
enteros consecutivos es menor que 54
digamos que tienes equis que es el
primer entero el primer entero y después
x más uno es el siguiente el próximo
están diciendo que la suma de estos dos
es menor que 54 entonces x + x + 1 es
menor que 54 y si en realidad quieres
averiguar quién es x bueno simplemente
resuelves esta desigualdad verdad ahora
vámonos hace se invierte una cantidad de
dinero al 5 por ciento de interés anual
entonces sea x la cantidad de dinero la
cantidad de dinero muy bien está
invertido en un 5 por ciento de interés
anual ok entonces al final del año es
más que igual a 250 cuál es el interés
de ven el interés al final del año
entonces esta es la cantidad de dinero
que inviertes x tu tasa de interés anual
es decir por el 5 por ciento o bien 0.05
y esto lo multiplicamos por la cantidad
de dinero invertido
ok eso será más que igual a esto va a
ser la cantidad de interés verdad que
tengo al final
lo que gano al final será mayor o igual
mayor o igual que 250 así que eso es lo
que hicimos establecimos el problema
como una desigualdad ahora vámonos a la
parte d
muy bien parte de compras hamburguesas
en un restaurante de comida rápida una
hamburguesa cuesta punto 49 dólares
tienes por lo más 3 dólares para gastar
escribe una desigualdad describe bueno
vamos a escribir la sea h igual al
número de hamburguesas al número de
hamburguesas
hamburguesas muy bien así que el total
que voy a gastar es el número de
hamburguesas multiplicado por la
cantidad de cada hamburguesa x 0.49
verdad que es esa es la cantidad total
de que voy a gastar y esto tiene que ser
menor o igual a 3 dólares verdad menor o
igual que 3 dólares
así que eso es nuestra desigualdad
hagamos el problema 4 aquí mismo
aunque vámonos al problema 4 comprueba
que el número dado es una solución a la
desigualdad correspondiente muy bien
parte a vámonos aquí la desigualdad es 2
que multiplica a x + 6 y es menor o
igual que 8 por equis y dicen que x es
igual a 12 nos preguntan si es una
solución vamos a verificarlo si ponemos
un 12 aquí vamos a hacerlo con un color
diferente entonces ponemos 2 en lugar de
x así que tienes 2 que multiplica a 12 6
que es 2 por 18 es menor o igual que 8
por 12 que no es otra cosa más que 196
muy bien entonces 2 por 18 son 36 y esto
es menor o igual que 96 entonces x igual
a 12 es una solución verdad porque se
satisface la desigualdad vámonos a la
parte de arte b tenemos 1.4 que
multiplica a zeta
+ 5.2 y queremos ver si es mayor que 0.4
por z en este caso para la solución si z
es igual a menos 9 ok vamos a tomarnos 7
igual a menos 9 algunos le llaman 9
negativo pero bueno no importa entonces
tenemos 1.4 x menos 9 ok más 5.2
queremos ver si es mayor que 0.4 por
menos nueve menos nueve ok entonces voy
a usar la calculadora para esto para
para ahorrar tiempo así que digo puedes
hacerlo como cálculo mental si quieres
pero para fines del ejercicio vamos a
hacerlas entonces tenemos en el lado
izquierdo 1.4 que multiplica
- 99 y esto va a ser igual a menos 12
puntos 6
- 12.6 y les sumamos ahora 5.2 y nos da
menos 7.4 y entonces del lado izquierdo
ok el lado izquierdo tengo menos 7.4 y
están afirmando que esto es mayor que
así que esto lo podemos hacer
mentalmente verdad 4 por 9 son 36
tenemos un número decimal así que
recordemos el número decimal 1 a la
izquierda y además multiplicamos por
menos nueva verdad entonces les está
diciendo que menos 7.4 es mayor que
menos 3.6 verdad que menos 3.6 y esto no
es verdad si dibujamos una recta
numérica aquí digamos que este es el
cero
aquí tenemos menos 3.6 y acanda el menos
7.4 que es mucho menor que menos 3.6 así
que éste no es verdad
no pondré en un gran color rojo no es
verdad se iguala -9 no es solución a
esta desigualdad de aquí no satisface la
desigualdad
vámonos a la parte c
parte ce tenemos menos cinco menos cinco
medios porque más un medio es menor que
menos 18 y nos lo piden no nos están
afirmando que ya igual a 40 es una
solución vamos a ver menos 5 medios por
40 más un medio es menor que menos 18 y
eso es su afirmación así que cinco
medios x 40 digamos dividimos primero
así que se vuelve 20 y luego
multiplicamos por 5 esto es menos 100
más un medio es menor que menos 18 bueno
puedes verlo como menos 99 con un medio
99 con un medio
puedes hacerlo en la cabeza verdad esto
es como menos 99.5 muy bien y esto es
menor que menos 18 que es
definitivamente cierto verdad esto es
mucho más negativo que el menos 18 así
que esta es correcta
finalmente vámonos a la parte de vámonos
a la parte de déjenme desplazarme hacia
abajo o déjenme hacer un poco de espacio
a quitar esta recta muy bien
vámonos ahora sí a la parte d
parte d
está diciendo que 80 es mayor o igual
que 10 por tres temas 2
y están afirmando que t 0.4 es una
solución vamos a ver 80 es mayor o igual
que 10 por 33 por t que en este caso es
0.4 más 2 que entonces más 80 es mayor o
igual que 10 por 3 por punto 4 es 1.22 y
80 es mayor o igual que 10 por 1.2 más
dos es 3.2 ok o que 80 es mayor o igual
que 32 verdad sólo recorremos el punto
decimal y esto es absolutamente cierto
así que también de es una solución
válida vámonos al problema 5 ahora
el costo de una ford focus es del 27 por
ciento del precio de una lexus gs 450h
si el precio de una ford es 15 mil
dólares así que vamos a escribirlo de
una vez fort si ford es igual a 15 mil
dólares cuál es el precio de una lexus
nos dice que la ford es igual al 27% del
precio de la lexus es decir de 0.27 o
27% que multiplica al precio de una
lexus
así que simplemente puedo escribir fl
pero bueno voy a dejar todas las letras
ahí así que la for sabemos que son
15.000 dólares y esto es igual al 27% o
al 0.27 que multiplica al precio de la
lexus muy bien así que para calcular el
precio de la lexus dividimos ambos lados
por 0.27 dividimos por 0.27 de ambos
lados
ok
eso se convierte en un 1 y así que
tienes que el precio de la lexus se
calcula como 15 mil 15 mil dólares /
0.27 vamos a ver que obtenemos
15.000
15000 dividido entre el 0.27 y eso nos
da 55 mil quinientos 55.55 así que
decimos 55 mil 556 para redondear hacia
arriba ok entonces tenemos que cuesta 55
mil 556 dólares así que estás gastando
mucho más en el lexus que lo que harías
en el ford focus debe ser a lo mejor un
mejor coche o qué sé yo verdad
finalmente vámonos al número 6 en su
nuevo trabajo puede ser pagado en uno en
una de dos maneras ok
puede ser pagado así que esta es una
opción uno
puede ser pagado y aquí vamos a escribir
la opción 2 muy bien puede ser pagado
con mil dólares por mes más 6% de
comisión de ingresos totales así que
definamos
vamos a definir sea ese igual a los
ingresos totales
tu primera opción serás pagó mil dólares
por mes más 6 por ciento de ingresos
totales así que cada mes será pagado mil
dólares más el 6% el 6% de la comisión o
los ingresos totales de eso es la opción
uno puede ser pagado mil pesos mil mil
dólares perdón por mes más el 6% y luego
la opción 12 mil 200 déjenme cambiar de
color la opción 2 lo haré en amarillo
pagamos 1200 al mes
ok más el 5% de comisión en ingresos ok
en compras mayores que 2000
más el 0.05 que es el 5% ok
así que si mis ingresos son ese digamos
si mis ingresos más que 2000 ok déjenme
escribirlo como ese menos 2000
aunque si mis ingresos son digamos que
son tres mil en un mes los ingresos
mayores que dos mil son tres mil menos
dos mil verdad eso es lo que supera los
dos mil esto será simplemente mil mil
dólares en ese ejemplo que les puse
déjenme destacarlo allí ok y ellos dicen
para qué cantidad de los ingresos es la
primera opción mejor que la segunda
supón que siempre hay ingresos mayores
que 2000 así que están esencialmente
diciendo que esta parte de ahí no sea
nula verdad así que mejor probablemente
significado para mí sería que gane más
dinero así que cuando es la opción 1
queremos ver cuando la opción 1 es mayor
o igual que la opción 2 entonces vamos a
resolver vamos a resolver esta
desigualdad
la primera cosa es que restamos mil
dólares de ambos lados ok si restamos
mil desde el lado izquierdo simplemente
nos queda 0.06 s que es mayor o igual
que si restamos 1000 del lado derecho
nos quedan simplemente 200 más 0.05 por
s menos 2000 verdad muy bien
digamos probablemente quiero
multiplicarlo esto va a ser 200 más 0.05
s menos menos cuántos 0.05 por 2000 es
decir el 5% que es lo mismo que un
veinteavo verdad entonces un veinteavo
de 2000 simplemente es 100 verdad esto
ya sería menos 100
así que 0.05 por 2000 es 100 ok que es
el 5% así que esto es el lado derecho de
la desigualdad entonces del lado
izquierdo tenemos 0.06
y del lado derecho tenemos simplemente
que 200 menos 100 se van verdad y nos
quedan simplemente 100 así que vamos a
escribirlo así 0.06 es mayor o igual que
0.05 y aquí me faltó la jce y déjenme
escribirla aquí va la s y esto es mayor
o igual que 0.05 s más 100 muy bien
ahora restemos 0.05 s de ambos lados de
la ecuación y ya casi terminamos verdad
porque si lo restamos vamos a tener que
0.06 menos 0.05 es 0.01 de ese y esto es
mayor o igual que
nos queda simplemente si en verdad así
que 100 y ahora simplemente dividimos
ambos lados por 0.01
entonces 0.01 x 0.01 esto nos da un 1 y
entonces se va a quedar que s es mayor o
igual que 100 entre sí entre 0.01 cuánto
es eso bueno esto es la misma cosa que
dividir 100 sobre 1 entre 100 verdad y
que simplemente es multiplicar por 100
verdad y 100 por 100 son 10.000 así que
la opción 1 es definitivamente mejor
para ti si tus ingresos totales para el
mes si tus ingresos totales si ése es
mayor o igual que 10.000 si es menor que
eso debes escoger la opción 2
deberías escoger la opción 2